>> Chris: IT'S TIME TO PLAY
THE TWENTY-FIFTEENIES.
NOW WE WOULD LIKE TO GIVE OUT
AWARDS FOR THE DUMB STUFF THAT
HAPPENED IN 2015.
BEST ALBUM, BEST DRAKE DANCE
MOVE, BEST CHRISTIAN VLOGGERS
WHO FAKED A PREGNANCY.
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT MADE OUR
SHOW INTERESTING THIS YEAR AND
GAVE US CONTENT.
WILL I SHOW YOU AN IMAGE OF A
2015 SUPERSTAR AND FOR 250
POINTS I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME THE
AWARD THEY SHOULD WIN.
FIRST UP, RACHEL DOLEZAL.
>> BEST INTERPRETATION OF
MICHAEL JACKSON'S BLACK OR WHITE
VIDEO.
>> Chris: POINTS, GENIUS, YES.
NEXT UP, THE POPE.
>> PAPAL FATHER, MOSHE KASHER.
>> FIRST COOL POPE EVER AWARD.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES.
THAT IS WHAT I LIKE, NOT A LAUGH
BUT APPLAUSE.
>> THE POPE DROPPING SOME SICK
BEATS ON THE MIC.
BEAT BOX.
I DIDN'T MEAN JEWY JEWY JEWY.
YOU LOOKED RIGHT AT MOSHE.
>> THE POPE IS LIKE I LIKE THAT
JOKE.
>> Chris: NEXT, AIDS DRUG
DICKBAG MARTIN SHKRELI.
>> GUY SO WHITE AND SO LAME I
WILL PROBABLY PLAY HIM IN A
FILM.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> ALSO, WINNER OF THE PIZZA RAT
LOOK ALIKE CONTEST.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS, THAT'S
RIGHT.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS THAT
GRABBED OUR
ATTENTION THIS YEAR WAS THE
THING EVERYONE
LOOKED AT WHERE THEY SAW A
DIFFERENT COLOR, LIKE ONE OR THE
OTHER.
AND THEY COULDN'T-- NO, NO.
NO THE OTHER ONE, YES, THE
DRESS.
JUST A REMINDER THAT REALITY IS
SUBJECTIVE AND WE ARE ALL FLAWED
CREATURES WHO WILL SOME DAY DIE
ALONE.